(boom)
- It's more delicious
than pot.
Nobody likes the taste of pot.
And if you say you do,
- Whoa.
- [Kelsey] you lying
(dramatic music)
and you're stoned.
And open your goddamn
eyes and have a drink.
- Look, we all like to
unwind here and there.
(light music)
Booze. Weed.
Who says you can't have 'em both?
I'm saying that.
You really should not have them both.
I do not recommend it.
Booze versus weed.
Please party responsibly.
It's debatable.
(dramatic patriotic music)
- My name is Maci
(soft dramatic music)
and I love to get drunk.
- My name is Yessica and
I smoke weed everyday.
- I'm Kelsey, I'm an alcoholic.
- I'm for weed.
- My name's Robin and I
have fun when I'm drunk.
- I'm Chris and I'm 420 Friendly.
(dramatic music)
- [Kelsey] Being drunk
is simply way more fun
than being high.
- If there's someone I'm intimidated by
or I'm attracted to,
I'm more likely to talk to them and
engage in conversation if I'm drunk.
- Champagne.
Margaritas.
Moscow Mules.
There's none of that with weed.
- Ooh, child.
- There's like and
activeness when you're drunk.
You know, like you love
everybody and you make friends.
And like, pot doesn't make you do that.
Pot makes you go, "Should
we go to In-N-Out?"
- Almost all of my best,
most favorite memories
happened when I was drunk.
- Yeah, you can get drunk anywhere whereas
if you want to smoke weed and get stoned,
you kind of have to go
to a private area and
hope you don't get interrupted.
- You can go and do a speech
or something like that
that you were really nervous about.
- Do you do speeches drunk?
- I've seen you drunk.
- [Blonde Girl] Yeah.
- [Kelsey] And you're a
fun drunk.
- [Blonde Girl] Yeah.
You should see me
- [Kelsey] You're a
- [Blonde Girl] high.
- [Kelsey] fun drunk.
- I guarantee you would spend less on wine
then you would on
- [Yessica] Whoa.
- [Maci] an ounce of weed.
- Pot is so expensive.
- Oh shut your mouth.
This is not even an argument.
- In today's day and age,
you could probably get two grams for $25.
And that will like smoke
you out for like two weeks.
You and your friends.
- Drunk Yessica,
I start texting people,
my Snapchats get all sloppy,
I start doing the thing
that every one girl does
when you do this with your drink.
(laughing)
Why do I do that?
- When I'm stoned I'm very paranoid.
My concept of time is completely skewed.
I don't know if I'm making any sense.
- So, the last time that I got high,
I laid in bed for about
seven hours convinced that
I was actually dead.
It was torturous.
- Trust me girl, I have been there.
I've actually called the cops and be like,
"I think I'm dying."
It was fine.
(laughing)
- She's pro weed.
(dramatic music)
- [Chris] It's meditative.
It's calming.
There's a connection.
- I think a lot of
problems would be solved
if people just smoked a joint,
set around a campfire and talked about
the world problems.
- The thing is is that
you have same experiences
when you're high--
- [Kelsey] No!
- [Blonde Girl] Yes.
- [Kelsey] No.
- [Blonde Girl] Wait.
- [Kelsey] Nope.
- When you are a marijuana
smoker and you meet
another marijuana smoker,
there is a hit off
(snaps)
that happens that is like no other.
- You don't have to smoke
weed out of a joint.
You smoke weed out of a pipe.
You can do it out of a bong.
You can put it in a brownie.
- Since smoking weed,
I have stopped wanting to drink soda,
drink any sort of like artificial things.
I'm more into like
all-natural healthier things
to put into my body.
- ' Cause you're a hippy now.
- It's about music.
It's about love.
It's about talking about bigger ideas.
- Weed makes you get to
know who you are inside.
- I'm so confident that when I get high
I start thinking about
shit that I shouldn't be
thinking about like,
what is making my lungs
go up and down right now?
- It's like bringing a bottle of wine,
but in the 21st century.
You come and you bring
some bud for everyone,
and everyone enjoys each others bud.
And you're like, "Mm. This is some great
"quality bud.
"Where did you buy it?"
- I stopped smoking weed for awhile
and then got high for the first time,
and then I had sex it was like...
- See, I just didn't
know what was going on.
I was like, "How long am I taking?
"Is it three hours or is it 30 seconds?"
- You felt like you were dying.
There are people that actually die when
they drink a lot of alcohol.
- Weed is better.
It doesn't cause you to die.
It doesn't cause you to drive drunk.
You're like, "Mm, I think I'm
just gonna stay here, dude."
- I don't think you go,
"Yeah, alcohol culture's
"about love."
I don't think that's the case.
- The reason bars sell alcohol is because
you have to be drunk to be
around sweaty horny strangers
who are like, "I'm gonna like your feet
"and not call you tomorrow."
- What fucking bars
are you going to?
(laughing)
(dramatic music)
- [Kelsey] You do shit.
You talk to more people.
It's like a being on
cocaine without actually
having to do cocaine.
- [Robin] I like to dance.
I like hugs.
And I like to do it all when I'm drunk.
- I do all those things stoned.
- I personally am a
better, more fun person
when I'm drunk.
- It's not a city of love,
but when you're high,
it will be.
(laughing)
(dramatic music)
- What?
What?
- [Blonde Girl] James and the
Giant Peach when you're high and tell me--
- They're all spider ladies.
Are you kidding me?
That thing is freaky as hell.
(dramatic patriotic music)